all right climate change activists in
London are bringing parts of the city to
a standstill a week-long series of
protests has disrupted roads and
railways police have made more than 400
arrests but the demonstrators are still
taking action Ian Lee is in one of those
affected areas in London and good
morning good morning this is Oxford
Circus in central London on a typical
day hundreds of thousands of commuters
would be moving through here it's one of
the busiest areas in the city but today
as you can see it's a protest camp with
a carnival-like atmosphere these
protesters call themselves extinction
rebellion across London they've been
causing chaos disrupting mass transit
systems and preventing cars using roads
all in the name of climate change the
police have made hundreds of arrests and
we've seen protesters who blew
themselves to a train and as well as you
can see they've parked a boat in the
middle of the street so what will it
take to get them to go away their
demands include the government declaring
a climate emergency and passing laws to
make the UK carbon neutral by 2025 some
climate change scientists say that's an
unrealistic timeline but that's not
stopping protestors who say they'll be
out here for the next 11 days unless
their demands are met but the real
question is how long will the police and
politicians put up with that gale
there's a question thank you very much
Ian Lee reporting from London